hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger on
today's episode is very different from
the last episode in that I'm kind of all
over the place there is not a singular
build like the station build of the last
episode and I'm working on but rather
I'm doing all kinds of things around the
park trying to bring everything together
and tie up the loose ends by doing also
to foliage work path work small scenery
items and some larger scenery elements
like a small snack shop so without
further ado let's get into the
time-lapse so I wanted to start this
episode off with something that you'd
probably know by now is a bit of a an
obsession for me recently and that is
making custom lampposts especially for a
theme like this there aren't too many
there aren't too many lampposts in the
game to begin with but there aren't
really too many themed specific
lampposts the ones that are there are
quite generic and not very different
whereas I feel lampposts and similar
details are some of the smallest was
most important things to add an ambience
to a certain area to add to the
atmosphere of the theme that you want to
carry over with it so in this case since
I want to go for an Alpine sort of Belle
Epoque sort of theme so it's all very
Victorian I wanted to go with some more
are Nouveau kind of lampposts something
with a lot of iron work a lot of
detailing and because if that's there
really isn't anything like that in the
game and I had to make something myself
so this is basically the results I'm
actually not really not making this for
the first time in this recording I'm
trying to remake it from the lampposts
that I made earlier while not recording
because trying to come up with a design
for these was very messy and very much a
process of trial and error especially
texture-wise since there aren't really
exactly any metal elements that you can
use to build these iron work detailing
with so instead you sort of have to look
for certain things that have that have
that similar texture and which you can
make similarly dark and which you can
put together in sort of strange ways to
make it look as though it's actually
decorative iron work so that's that
lamppost there are a few lamps on it to
make it seem a little bit
larger than the in-game imposts it's
definitely a little bit larger than
human skill so I won't be using it too
much it's really just an elements that I
want to put in some of the most
grandiose sight lines of the park but
then again that's also for me a bit of a
points especially when it comes to path
works and this is something you might
also know by now I really like to switch
up stuff so I don't want to use the same
fences all over the park and definitely
think it's much more fun and much better
to use all kinds of different fences
even within a single area and I think
the same goes for lampposts so I really
want to use all kinds of different
lampposts and use different kinds of
lampposts in different areas so for
example this one will be used more
alongside the larger Boulevard along
with this small fence that I'm actually
making for it this is sort of a set that
goes together so yeah I'm placing it
here alongside this somewhat large
Bolivia that'll be alongside the
restaurant and really be one of the
major sight lines of the park but for
some of the less important paths are
just beginning to some simple wooden
lights that are much more drawn back
don't really draw as much attention as
these lampposts and will just be a lot
cheaper as well and those are the things
that I'm getting to right now so that
was actually a pretty good accidental
Segway one little trick now I think is
quite neat that you can use with some of
these Christmas detailing which you just
told me do in a second there is you can
put together these these 2d gingerbread
decorations and put them together very
close together in like there's only a
little bit of air between them and then
put a bunch of them next to each other
so it actually looks as though they are
the 3d which is something that you could
normally do with 2d Alfa textures and
something which I don't think any object
in the game does although I definitely
don't have enough of an understanding to
know but you can basically put together
a bunch of these 2d objects very close
to each other to sort of make them look
too
3d so I think that's a pretty neat trick
also I put some billboard scenery items
like the billboard mounts that you have
into the wooden planks over there to
sort of make it look as though the
wooden plank is actually hammered onto
the wooden posts of the land so I think
that object actually works quite well
for making those nails and I think it it
kind of makes the look of that
particular lamppost a little bit
stronger because and you can using quite
a few things sometimes you'll just see
these lampposts where you can very
clearly tell that there is just one
diagonal plank sort of stuck to the
other posts that the lamppost is made
out of and you could just see the nails
and any things and sometimes they'll use
ropes to connect them but in any case
it's sort of lo-fi lamps that are a bit
you know they're a bit sort of non
entirely well put together they're sort
of made to look a bit rickety like that
and that's the sort of look that I
wanted to go forward with these lamps as
well and the great thing about having
three different lamps instead of just
making one is that you can sort of have
some very small variations along the
park and every path has a slightly
different lamppost I just now realized
you probably shouldn't be stunning
drinking games with me saying the word
lamppost in this episode mmm so this
thing right here is a park map I know it
doesn't look like one it'll probably
still be quite a while until I have
something that's good enough to actually
put a park map in there but the idea is
that this would be a pretty good place
to place a park map it's really a place
where a lot of things come together and
even if that doesn't work out I think
you could even make it into a aqtime
sort of billboard I haven't actually
seen those too much but I was at
Fantasia lent recently and even though
phantasialand has the worst Internet
reception ever like I was supposed to
meet up with a few guys in Fantasia
Island and I've actually been strolling
around the park for an hour on my own
because I couldn't get internet anywhere
eventually found one loan
corner in the park with reception that
was literally not even kidding the most
dead part of the park with no ride but
yeah they decide they have no connection
no internet so you're completely in
terminus invitation and at least I was
but what they do have is these these
boards that tell you all the queue times
like they don't have an app they don't
really have internet so it's not that
high-tech as many parts we all have but
they do have those very neat boards
which show you all the queue times for
all the coasters which is something
that's actually quite cool about the
park and they're even sort of the own
meeting spaces like they're placed at
some of the most busy and importance
interchanges of the paths around the
park but you can really see just groups
of people grouping together around those
big announcement boards actually see
what the queue times are and where they
should go next which is quite handy
especially since they're sort of at
Forks on the road so you can still use
them as a way to sort of decide your way
around the park so yeah whatever is
gonna happen with that billboard I
thought that is a very important point
when you want to have something like
that so I just put that in there for
future use whatever we're gonna do with
it eventually now over here is a little
bit of regular path work just putting
rocks and lampposts everywhere to make
everything seem a little bit more alive
I'm very afraid of creating a large open
space with these pots especially
considering how fast these posts are and
there isn't really anything that I can
put in the middle of these so I'm trying
as much as I can to use all of these
trees and all of the planters in order
to sort of break up the paths and give
this park more of a forest look to it
so moving on and this is full of my
favorite things of the episode one of my
favorite things of the entire park
actually so far this is a small store
for fries that's pretty much it it's
just a little building it was inspired
by one of the buildings in Planet bro
coaster actually
I'm sorry I need to shout out planets
bro coaster once again I don't know how
many times this has happened already but
I was just strolling around their park
looking for stuff just looking around
because it's just fun to to look around
in the park and just sort of pretend
that it's real
and then it isn't real and it kind of
sucks because you're in a video game but
in any case I was just walking about the
pike and saw this building and it's just
a tiny little building it was slightly
offset it's a little bit messy and has
loose planks and loose rocks but it it
was really charming and I figured I
wanted something like that just a little
bit bigger and more suited to the theme
of Jaeger horn but something like that I
think it would be quite good for this
team especially since we have this large
plaza over here that doesn't really have
any buildings or anything of attention
other than the Pfister that you have of
the coaster so I thought I thought this
was a perfect place to put some some
kind of small building which you can go
to and do something with some kind of
interaction with the scenery so this is
a small building that sells price and
that's really just about it it's a
little bit of a messy building to be
honest since it is inspired by that sort
of thing but at the same time I didn't
want to bring back some of the ideas of
the Swiss Chalet style that you see in
the station and the church so there is a
little bit of that that Gable and
decoration that you see and it's quite a
detailed building actually I ended up
taking quite some time to stick all of
the wooden posts and blanks together
into this building to shape out all the
little details that make this very
simple and rustic but I think it's a
pretty charming building in the end it's
nothing big it definitely doesn't want
to draw attention to itself it's really
just there to add to the surroundings
instead of drawing attention from the
surrounding still building itself but I
think it's important to have stuff like
this around in your parks even just from
a functional perspective there wasn't
really any place to eat yet and even
though there will be a restaurant very
close to this you know very often you
don't really want to sit down in a
restaurant you just want to quickly pick
up some fries and maybe spent like 10
minutes
at Max and I just hope into the next
ride so something that you that can
serve you really quickly and get you on
your way to writing more coasters is
something that whatever you really
needed I think so
when it comes to the general detailing
it's very similar on the front side as
compared to the back side the only
problem was it's a slightly offset
building like the right side it goes
down a little bit more which i partly
did to make it look interesting but
partly just to fit that bit or pour it
in there that says that this is the
monster if it's or excuse my french
pronunciation that this is you know that
the place where you can get price I want
to have as much space for advertising in
the end after all since no this is a
theme park we need to make money so um I
do have that in there but I think it
does amp to the building quite a bit and
next to this I had a bit of grass and I
figured it would be a better idea to
fill this up with a bit of theming
to create the sort of atmosphere of
having a forest rather than putting some
parts over here or turning this into one
big seating area because ideally I don't
want to turn this into an area where
you're gonna sit this is really a part
from which you'll be walking toward
Jaeger horn because from this direction
you do have a probably one of the best
sight lines toward the church and the
coaster itself so I really wanted to use
this as a path where people don't do
anything but walk toward Jaeger horn and
see Jaeger horn in the distance but when
you're standing in line for this this
stall if there is a line at all you also
have a really good view of the of the
church but it does break it up a little
bit which I guess is interesting as well
if you're if you're walking toward yeah
get on you'll see this tiny building
standing between you and Jaeger Nolan
and I think it's an uninteresting
looking building enough to the point
where it doesn't really draw your
attention away from the scene that
you're supposed to look at being the
coaster itself but it does sort of give
you this this reference point in front
of it so you have some interesting
perspective play I think like you'll see
the this this very small building with
some trees and decorations around it
in the front and then in the back you'll
see the hill sort of loom in the
distance high up which is actually
really all that height but since the
church building is on a small scale and
this building is actually on a human
scale and there's this big gap between
these paths and the the mountain itself
where there's this little valley that
the coaster goes through I think
everything looks quite a bit larger and
the first perspective does come into
play a bit it's making an actually look
as though you're walking toward a
mountain now over here
I'm just doing some very simple foliage
simple to the point where I didn't want
to keep the valley itself completely
foliage less and just put some grass in
there because I really wanted to have
that to keep the view in text and still
make it look as though the mountain is
bigger than it really is
but at the same time I didn't want to
have some foliage and decoration
alongside the path so there's this sort
of row of small trees and bushes going
alongside the path come alongside the
Bulevar and the fences and the lamps but
it isn't really that much there's still
the grass behind it and you can still
have a perfect clear view of the
mountain and the roller-coaster behind
it as well particularly this is a pretty
funny thing actually I recently listened
to a podcast with God I forgot his name
I'll look him up in the meantime but I
recently listened to a podcast with the
designer of Fantasia Lent or at least
somebody who played a huge role in the
design of black mamba in the design of
chapels and even the design of Clue came
recently and funnily enough he himself
are right there we go
his name was Eric Dunham and he's from
Belgium and funnily enough he himself
was kind of afraid of roller coasters
like at the time of listening to that
podcast he hadn't even written black
mamba yet ever but I thought was what
was really interesting about his way of
designing and something that I think I
can even sort of see back with myself
since for a long time I was afraid of
roller coasters as well is designing
coasters for the people
who don't write them instead of
designing them for the people who do
write them so what you'll see with many
of the rights at phantasialand is that
the roller coasters have so many paths
going around them and going through
their areas with all kinds of places
where you can stand or sit and just look
at the coaster that you know it's almost
more of an experience to look at the
coaster than to just ride it and the
people don't dare to go on the coaster
have a really good interaction with the
coaster that way as well I actually feel
this way about Baron 1898 I always enjoy
it more - look at that coaster than to
ride it although that's kind of because
it's not that intense but still it's
it's something that I want to keep in
mind with my projects as much as I can
as well so I always try to design
coasters for the people who are not
going to ride it and I think the same
goes for a Jaeger horn as well even
though it's a family ride not everybody
is going to get on it even if it still
applies to the largest demographic that
you can so there are plenty of benches
and plenty of paths when you have a lot
of interaction with the ride itself and
I want to keep those as clear as
possible like simultaneously I want to
make the area look as forested as
possible in place as many trees as I can
but at the same time I don't wanna break
open the sight lines between the paths
and the coasters so I'm actually three
placement is something that I'm super
careful about and something that I can
take a lot of time actually just very
slightly moving trees and then moving
the camera to see how it looks and
getting the exact placement where you
can use the tree to get the the the
forest the atmosphere from its but at
the same time not break up the sight
lines that you want to keep insects see
how that's something that your see me do
quite a bit in in Jaeger horn as well
and it's definitely something that comes
back with the idea of having that
Bulevar sort of run alongside the valley
that the coaster goes through with a
restaurant and that stall for fries but
also this dis path bridge going over the
coaster and having just these very
simple fences alongside the side I know
these fences probably wouldn't have done
it in the US this was actually something
that
I came to realize only recently when
some Americans were very surprised at
how small the fences around
phantasialand are and how they're all
just themed instead of huge metal fences
that completely prevent you from coming
very close to the coasters like you can
almost touch Taran and it's not that
hard to get out of the path and actually
go into that area even though you should
never do it I personally like it when
the employees keep their kosis as open
as possible like when you can come close
enough that you do feel as though you're
not you know as though they're not
keeping you away from the coaster even
even when it's still safe see how we're
just using some simple fences that you
know when 100 percents keep you out of
it spur will just make it pretty clear
you know you're not supposed to jump
into the area of the coaster and it's
still quite hard to do it but your view
of the coaster isn't really obstructed
and the fences are there to add to the
theme rather than being huge metal
fences that only subtracts from the
theme itself and to that end also
keeping all of the foliage around this
area quite low and quite simple so you
can still look at the coaster you can
see the paths from the coaster itself as
well and I was actually really happy to
start theming this area because this is
the first sort of Numb mountain area
we've got the very clear divide on the
coaster between the mountain area which
is up quite high and the second part of
the coaster where it just sort of dips
through these lower valleys and where it
has more interaction with the station
and the queues and the rest of its
strike so this was sort of the the first
part of the letter pawn of the ride and
even though it's still part of the first
part of the ride but it's where it sort
of dips into the other side so this was
a bit of an experiment to see like to
what extent I could I could get the
Alpine look into the surroundings of the
coaster without completely breaking open
the sight lines because this is this is
a very important part of the environment
here and something that I really wanted
to keep as open as possible since right
here is where pretty much all the the
paths look
station building and also we're from
another path you can see the mountain of
Jaeger horn as well alongside the cosa
station and the cosa track so I wanted
to keep this open keep all the foliage
very low and keep as much grass as I
could over here so I'm sort of
experimenting to see how all of that is
going to look also this is where I
experimented for a little bit making a
small stone pot using these pillar
pieces now for a while I sort of messed
up and just used square pieces but at
some point I realized I can actually
sort of use the terrain in your
advantage since you can very slightly
slide certain pieces to the to the part
where they're invisible and give them
different shapes other than squares
which can actually give you a pretty
convincing stone path look I think even
though there are quite small stones and
they don't really have any difference in
texture and even if there is they're
very slight differences I think it's
something that at least sells the look
of it quite a bit and this is actually
where I'm going a little bit far in
trying to theme everything because this
path is obviously not really supposed to
be used by anybody it's just for
evacuation purposes if there if the
train could stall in that little valley
of the curve right there which to be
honest it could actually then this is
the part that you're going to want to
take to take all of the people under the
coaster which is pretty quick but I
still wanted a statement as much as we
can so again we have the path being made
by the fountains with a very fitting
texture I think for the surroundings
there is a small stone path a small sort
of wooden bridge over the track itself
and also that little wooden door which I
guess people could very easily use to
get into the coastal area but hey that's
that's something I'm not going to be
worried about too much honestly my
personal view is just that you shouldn't
be too ridiculous about safety around
rollercoasters and you know just leave
it open to common sense nobody is gonna
walk onto rollercoaster Trek but then
again how are you gonna stop people
completely from doing that and who's
gonna stop them from filing lawsuits
when something does go wrong
that's that's rolling out something I
want to get into too far but god I just
I just like it when parks just no leave
you be and don't completely stop you
from going everywhere and just you know
let you down to your own common sense of
not going into the right areas because
that's that's just how it should be now
I'm just doing a little bit of extra
clutter over here by any my ever
favorite piece that water well I I think
I can hardly stop myself from adding
that whenever the theme allows it this
is one of those very small things that
you can just put in anywhere and over
here I'm doing my best to take the bro
basics foliage tutorial in there and get
some nature neater in I should say which
if you still haven't seen it this is
something that I should totally still
link in this video even though I found a
new now it's already and talks about in
multiple videos the bro basics about
nature is an amazing planet coaster
episode about doing foliage in different
ways whether you're going for completely
natural foliage completely man-made
foliage or is the thing that sits of in
between and is the man-made planted
foliage with all kinds of arrangements
of bushes and trees that is clearly
man-made but looks as if it's sort of
natural it's trying to look natural and
that's something which really comes back
quite a lot in iaeger horn because
obviously all of these arrangements of
bushes and everything is planted there
and it's definitely not natural but at
the same time it's trying to look like
it's nature I'm trying to fit the look
of a whole large forest and mountain
area into a few square meters everywhere
so sort of hyper condensed into that
small version I'm not entirely sure how
much I like certain parts like I'm
really keeping the pallets very
restricted I'm only using a lot of dark
colors and using just a few of the
foliage items that we have in the planet
coaster and trying to avoid all of the
the more tropical and light shrubs but
so far I'm actually pretty happy with it
so yeah we'll see how far we could take
this and maybe if in the future we'll
have some more foliage into the game
that can fit into this area so here I'm
just getting to some more path elements
and I think this is the last sort of
main thing that I'm getting to in this
episode I already wanted to get a
signpost
into this square here since it's
probably the most important meeting
point of different paths in the park and
also the one where you're gonna have to
direct the guests into the area where
they can actually get into the coaster
nothing is worse than walking around an
attraction with all these beautiful
pawns but having no idea where the queue
actually starts and also directing the
guests toward the restaurant and the
exit of the park all that sort of stuff
and also here I want to get into using
some slightly different borders around
these paths
I'm not entirely sure yet what I'm gonna
do with these putts for the longest time
I've sort of promised myself that I'm
gonna build buildings next to these but
yeah that would take a lot of time to do
so that's my only thing sort of stopping
me from really deciding for a good that
I'm gonna do something like that but for
now I'm pretty fine with just leaving
this with foliage and some simple path
curbs and other elements also a bench
that you can sit on because I love it
where you could just have that wall that
people can actually sit on I think the
bench texture that wooden bench texture
actually adds coin a lot to the wall but
it also quite like adds something to the
game I feel when people actually sit on
a wall because to be honest that's
that's kind of what people do if you're
in a theme park and you've been walking
around for all day like literally I will
sit on anything I'll sit on cue railings
all the time and whenever there is a
flat surface that's anywhere between 50
centimeters and a meter tall I'll sit on
it for sure so I just love it when
people sit on random things and when you
can get the guests to sit on random
things that might not look hmm sorry
I might have actually said then I still
have a cord and I think I have yet so
here goes I still have a cold and I'm
trying to one take wonder if this
recording so I'm sorry about that but um
yeah basically people will sit on
anything in a theme park
that's the message especially if you're
me maybe I shouldn't project my feelings
onto everybody else but I'm pretty sure
that many people are gonna sit on many
different things and get very creative
to be able to sit anyway so um
yeah with just a little bit of clutter
left with some simple barrels and boxes
around the restaurants or the fries
though I should say I'm ending up this
episode and that has been it for this
episode of
Yaeger on so thank you guys for watching
I hope you guys enjoyed and I'll see you
in the next episode in which I'm not
sure what I'm working on but it's
probably going to be the cue see ya bye
guys
see you later
[Music]